Bild hatte es schon lange gefordert die
Wände im Atomstreit im Streit um die
Laufzeiten der Atomkraftwerke atomkraft
ja bitte vor allem ja auch wegen der
Entwicklung auf dem Energiemarkt den
drohenden Winter vor Augen die
explodierenden Stromkosten in Sicht so
genau deswegen fordert Bild schon seit
Monaten verschiebt das endgültige Aus
der Atomkraft in Deutschland und jetzt
ist klar die Atomkraftwerke laufen
tatsächlich weiter der erste Schritt zur
AKW Wende ist getan
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
will jetzt also doch zwei Atomkraftwerke
am Netz lassen stand jetzt und diese
beiden Meiler sind damit gemeint einmal
Neckarwestheim in Baden-Württemberg und
dieser zwei in München für die beiden
war ja nur eine Notreserve geplant jetzt
sollen sie aber zumindest bis Mitte
April weiterlaufen zum einen um für mehr
stromsicherheit hier bei uns in
Deutschland zu sorgen und zum anderen um
Frankreich zu helfen die gerade Probleme
bei der Stromproduktion haben da dort
aktuell mehr als die Hälfte der AKW
gewartet wird
denn sich also diese Prognosen nicht in
der Gegenteil verkehren dann muss ich
heute schon als für die
Energiesicherheit verantwortlicher
Minister sagen dass dieser zwei und
Neckarwestheim im ersten Quartal 23 wohl
am Netz bleiben werden das ist der Stand
heute das will ich ausdrücklich sagen
das Gesetz des Verfahren muss ja noch
durchgeführt werden aber die Entwicklung
in Frankreich ist in den letzten Wochen
deutlich schlechter gewesen als
eigentlich prognostiziert und insofern
ist es das Szenario mit dem wir im
Moment rechnen müssen
unsere bild-reporterin Annika rasch für
uns am Kanzleramt guten Morgen Annika
zwei AKWs bleiben jetzt doch am Netz
warum ausgerechnet jetzt
genau Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
begründet das mit der stromsituation
Frankreich die sei nun schlechter als
erwartet und würde eben dann auch unsere
stromsicherheit hier gefährden wirklich
überzeugend ist das nicht weil diese
Lage in Frankreich ist schon lange
bekannt und kann eigentlich nicht über
Nacht sonderlich schlechter geworden
sein also die Begründung ist relativ
schwach noch laufen eben drei Meiler und
sollen dann eben über das Jahr über das
Jahresende eben noch hinauslauf aber nur
für eine kurze Zeit der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister steht ja eigentlich
für die Ideologie atomkraft nein danke
musste er sich jetzt von dieser
Ideologie komplett verabschieden oder
ist einfach nur auf Eis gelegt
ja eine lange Zeit Entscheidung ist es
nicht man spricht hier nur von einer
Laufzeit bis März also ist es praktisch
ja eine Zwischenlösung trotzdem ist
diese Entscheidung von Haarwerk
natürlich riskant vor den Wahlen in
Niedersachsen damit hat er sich selbst
natürlich geschadet und auch seiner
Partei die eben als zentrales
versprechen eben auch den Atomausstieg
hat vor diesen Wahlen aber dazu hinzu
kommt natürlich auch dass die Partei für
eine lange Zeit die eigenen Interessen
eigentlich höher gestellt hat als das
Gemeinwohl das heißt diese Entscheidung
diese plötzliche Kehrtwende von
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck dürfte also
seiner Partei vor den Landtagswahlen in
Niedersachsen nicht wirklich zugute
kommen Annika rasch vor dem
Bundeskanzleramt hier in Berlin vielen
Dank für das Gespräch
danke und zu dem Thema jetzt bei uns im
Studio bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer
schönen guten Morgen Jan guten Morgen
die ak-wende von Robert Habeck
ausgerechnet jetzt kommt sie noch
rechtzeitig für den Winter also sie
kommen rechtzeitig aber sie ist
natürlich nur ein erster und absolut
notwendiger Schritt an die Garage hat
sie ja gerade eben auch noch mal gesagt
es geht am Ende um zwei Meiler deren
Laufzeit erstmal bis Mitte April
verlängert werden kann und soll der
dritte Maler der steht im Emsland und
über den möchte Robert Habeck bisher gar
nicht sprechen bzw bis jetzt sagt Robert
Habeck auch dieser meiner geht ganz
planmäßig Ende des Jahres vom Netz wir
müssen uns das einmal nur noch mal
vergegenwärtigen wir sind einer
dramatischen Situation es gibt
Strommangel das heißt aus Frankreich
eine Garage die Reporterin hat sie ja
gerade eben auch noch mal gesagt
Frankreich ist aber nur ein Grund denn
am Ende geht es natürlich um den
Strombedarf auch hier in Deutschland
und wir kennen das im Winter wenn der
Strombedarf besonders hoch ist dass wir
zum Teil ja auch Atomstrom aus
Frankreich beziehen jetzt hat Robert
Habeck die Sorge dass das nicht der Fall
sein wird vielleicht muss sogar
umgekehrt Deutschland den Franzosen noch
aushelfen und deswegen kommt er zu einem
absolut richtigen überfälligen
Entschluss zu sagen mindestens zwei Mal
hier in Deutschland müssen erstmal für
ein paar Monate weiterlaufen jetzt haben
wir gleichzeitig die
Laufzeitverlängerung und das Gas Leck in
der Ostsee Zufall
da wird jetzt drüber spekuliert in der
Tat das ist jetzt beides an einem Tag
passiert aber wenn man auch sieht was in
den letzten Tagen und Wochen auch hier
in Deutschland im politischen in Berlin
vor allem diskutiert werden wurde dann
ist das aus meiner Sicht wirklich Zufall
dass das genauso gekommen ist Robert
Habeck sagt immer wir sind so gut es
geht bereits ja unabhängig schon von
russischem Gas am Ende geht es hier um
einfach die die Situation auf dem
europäischen Strommarkt und auch der
zehn Punkte Plan den Robert Habeck ja
gestern Abend vorgelegt hat der deutet
ganz klar darauf hin dass hier nicht
innerhalb von wenigen Stunden etwas
zusammengeschrieben wurde sondern da hat
man jetzt schon länger insgesamt
diskutiert wir wissen beispielsweise
auch von Preußen Electra noch am Morgen
haben wir gesprochen mit dem
Betreiberkonzern von Isar 2 dass dieser
Tagen in sehr sehr intensiven Gesprächen
auch mit Robert habe Gefahren über einen
Weiterbetrieb
so und jetzt kommt dieser Eilmeldung die
EU hält die Pipeline Sabotage für
wahrscheinlich und droht tatsächlich
auch mit Sanktionen die Europäische
Union hält der Sabotage als Ursache für
die lex an den Gaspipelines nordstream 1
und 2 für wahrscheinlich und hat mit
Gegenmaßnahmen gedroht alle verfügbaren
Informationen deuten darauf hin dass
diese Lex das Ergebnis einer
vorsätzlichen Handlung sind das erklärte
der EU-Außenbeauftragte Giuseppe am
Mittwoch im Namen der 27
Mitgliedsstaaten jede vorsätzliche
Störung der europäischen
Energieinfrastruktur werde mit einer
robusten und gemeinsamen Reaktionen
beantwortet werden so jetzt noch mal
jetzt haben wir es schwarz auf weiß
quasi
wir reden die ganze Zeit über einen
Verbleib der AKW reichen denn zwei AKW
tatsächlich jetzt aus um über diesen
Winter zu kommen das hängt immer davon
ab wie viel Strom die deutschen
verbrauchen und wenn es schon ein
reduzierten in dem Fall ganz normalen
Strombetrieb im Winter geben sollte da
ist der Bedarf einfach höher dann müssen
wir uns anschauen wie viel tragen denn
die Kernkraftwerke die drei noch am Netz
sind zum allgemeinen zu allgemeinen
Stromproduktion bei und da sehen wir
derzeit im Sommer Spätsommer Anfang
Herbst das ist so zwischen sieben und
acht Prozent sind wenn man jetzt diese
drei Kernkraftwerke herausnehmen würde
müsste man diese Stromlücke ja auffüllen
beispielsweise mit Kohlekraftwerken oder
auch mit Gas und das ist in dieser
aktuellen Situation in der wir uns
befinden natürlich der völlig falsche
Weg also wäre es absolut richtig diese
Werke länger am Netz Zulassung wir
sprechen dann wie gesagt über einen
Bereich so 7 8 Prozent den die beiden
die die drei Meile ausmachen wenn es
zwei sind dann sind es mutmaßlich so um
die fünf bis sechs Prozent ausgerechnet
jetzt in der Energie und teuer Krise
sagt der Kanzler die länderchefkonferenz
ab was ist das für ein Zeichen
das ist ein Zeichen dass man sich
zwischen Ländern und auch der
Bundesregierung noch nicht richtig
einiges was die Finanzierung angeht wir
müssen zum einen einmal sehen Olaf
Scholz hat Corona ist deswegen Isolation
hat sich in die Wohnung im Kanzleramt
zurückgezogen hatte für heute zu einem
großen bundländergipfel geladen über das
Thema Energiepreise aber vor allem über
die Frage wer bezahlt das am Ende denn
wir wissen dass die Länder fast 20
Milliarden selbst beitragen sollen zu
diesem großentlastungspaket dass er
insgesamt ein Volumen von 60 Milliarden
hat aber die Länder die streuen sich die
sagen nein nein wenn ihr was beschließt
Liebe Bundesregierung dann bezahlt das
bitte auch schön so und wir wissen auch
bei diesen Bund ländergipfeln da geht es
auch viel um diplomatier Olaf Scholz ist
jemand der auch gerne das direkte
Gespräch sucht mit dem einen oder
anderen Ministerpräsidenten das heißt
das kann er natürlich jetzt nicht machen
ich glaube dieser diplomatischen
Fähigkeit der fühlt er sich beraubt
dadurch dass er in Corona Isolation ist
die würde er gerne ausspielen deswegen
hat er dieses bundwendertreffen
verschoben es zeigt aber auch wie gesagt
es gibt noch viele viele offene Fragen
bei der Finanzierung man wäre heute mit
Olaf Scholz in Corona Isolation
sicherlich nicht zu einem Ergebnis
gekommen und deswegen sagt er gleich
dann vertragen wir uns auf nächste Woche
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch
[Musik]